so
come up to the mic if you don't mind
that way
this is being recorded so
uh others can listen
push make it red
there's a button nope down the bottom
there you go
sorry
uh the things that you left in
this i'm morgan gaines i'm the president
of the new hampshire midwife association
fantastic um
the things that you left in the
profession the midwifery profession like
is it still an advisory sort of
situation so we the oplc will
be
reaching out for
sort of like consult with the midwifery
council but still making the ultimate
decision there as far as like
medications and devices
scope of practice those sorts of things
and then is it ultimately still
the executive director's decision
if
the
as i understand the changes we're making
the idea is that the
executive director will make sure there
are rules regarding that
but
your organization and that with the
represented by the advisory board will
be making the technical decisions on the
scope of practice
and things like that
free counsel makes those actual those
decisions not the oplc
or together
together the oplc will probably be
nagging you to make sure you get them in
on time okay
all right thank you representative
allegro
morning everybody
i have to say that this this is a
broader um
view of this bill
and this was a turning point for me
because that move to try to form a board
with no midwives
on it
really opens my eyes and makes me very
concerned about the motivations
and um
the prime sponsor
yeah that's okay well you can ask her
that's okay no it's not your motivation
specifically
it's just the whole motivation of oplc
and it you know
when i first came on board here i
understood
what i thought was the purpose of oplc
but i'm becoming more and more reticent
to put more power into the hands of an
executive agency once again
right these guys they make the rules
they decide if the rule may have been
broken whether or not to initiate an
investigation they conduct the
investigation they render the verdict
they dictate the punitive actions
and
this is the same thing with a lot of
federal agencies
and i just really am hesitant about
putting more power into the hands
of oplc i'm going to be thinking about
that
every bill going forward
and this one i just i just don't
understand honestly so i understand the
intentions are good but i think our way
may be a little errant
so the you know as as we've
as we've talked about the the the
purpose of the creation of oplc
was very specific and i don't
i personally don't want to create an
empire that that is that is not the
intent the intent of the creation of
oplc was to
remove a tremendous amount of duplicated
functions in confusion frankly because
we had folks that cross professions
and there was no consistency to anything
so
again that's why you know going through
this there's certain administrative
things that that
seem to make sense with them
but on the flip side
of of giving too much to oplc the
alternative
what we've had is that we've had these
boards that have had tremendous power as
well
and how do we
balance that i guess is probably
because the same thing is that you know
whether it's the office of professional
licensure or the original board that was
created
that
you're still instilling a limited amount
or a substantial amount of power to a
limited amount of people
it's probably not relevant to the
current council
but 10 15 years ago when i first got
involved
the midwifery council was notorious for
having a director who kept all the
board's records in her back bedroom
and wouldn't share them
and it was a problem to get that solved
i don't
i believe it that has been solved
but
it's an example of what can happen when
you have a very small board
and one person in charge who who ran it
like her own kingdom
which
as i said it happened it happened you
know 10 15 years ago
yeah thank you and like i say i'm i'm
just rethinking these things i'm not
rendering my own decision right now
um
yeah thank you for that that
clarification which i was aware of but
you you added some things
verbs of show it
thank you
i'll add to
what representative mcguire said also
regarding oplc
this agency
was
originally put in place
to run a few boards
and they ended up
an executive decision was made to try
and consolidate many boards under it to
ease the burden of the clerical work
we did see
in the past that there seemed to be
a mindset of building empire there
i will say i don't i don't really see
that motivation
for the current leader but the
leadership changes and so that's what
we're trying to guard against
and yet still allow them to be able to
take over those administrative duties
and the clerical work
that the professions don't necessarily
need to be bothered with and to be more
efficient
and more efficient way to run state
government
yeah so this you know this is a broad
scope we're not really picking on
midwifery or any any specific group
because there's been examples of issues
in
multiple boards but that's why you know
going through the document here and
carving out what
rather than just dumping the whole thing
onto the oplc
saying okay there are some places where
it's appropriate for the professional
board to retain
and
you know what i mean so it it's it keeps
the it's spreading the power out in
essence yeah um yeah and and i don't
want to draw too much
off the track from
the focus of this meeting which is the
details of this bill sure but um you
know the the
again just for the last time in the
broader sense
you're right i mean a lot of power can
be accumulated in the hands of a board
whether or not it comes under oplc or
not
the difference is is that under oplc it
now brings the force of law of the state
uh so the board had the force of the law
for its rules
for
any rules that it may have have
generated the problem is that that some
of the boards didn't actually write
rules
right yeah these these boards were were
not
they were statutory boards
so
again that's
i think the uh
midwives have something that they want
to add to this
go for it
i'm sherry stevens i'm the chair of the
midwifery board
um
i'm sorry
i could take a long time and talk to you
about the history of the board
and the history of the relationship with
oplc but that's not the purpose of this
meeting
i have been on the board since 2015
and since then we have been
desperately trying to work with oplc
trying to get things to go through
trying to get things organized
watching them go through their growing
pains and getting
you know even our licensure online
done which is still a little bit of a
nightmare
and um
working through our investigations and
using all these different entities to
try to you know we're trying to be like
the purpose of you is to organize right
so you're you're going to organize our
our licensing process so that it's it's
much easier i've been doing it all
myself for years not because
i wanted to because there was nothing
else there to do and and i've reached
out to them
multiple times and saying you guys going
to take this over what do we need to do
and it wasn't until this last session
last fall that they finally took it over
and it was a nightmare it did not go
smoothly and it's not going to go
smoothly this spring because they
haven't got their software together and
so that's fine you know we're we as a
board
aren't trying to
take over the
um administrative duties we're happy to
work with somebody but also the
frustration level of handing over
you know our ability to license our you
know constituents are not constituents
but you know the the midwives right they
they need their licensure and if they're
it goes overdue because of
administrative duties we lose medicaid
we lose med mao we lose our ability to
order medications
and that's what's happening so
you know we really want this
organization to be organized and work
for us but taking it over
and and giving that power to somebody
else that isn't really
doing it for the midwives they're doing
it across the board if they got that
together they got their rules together
and every board had their same way of
running a meeting every board had their
same way of licensing all that stuff was
in place
happy we would be thrilled
but then what we see happening
is you're taking over midwifery at his
advisory board historically
has put midwifery out of business
there's other states that move midwifery
into an advisory board and it puts it in
a very vulnerable state because somebody
else can just decide nope we don't want
that anymore
and and it's gone even in vermont they
keep using vermont as a an example as an
advisory board they're very vulnerable
to whoever's in that position we would
be very vulnerable whoever is in that
position
of the executive director
and saying we want midwifery and they
don't and when you say oh we're not
trying to get rid of mid-referee
that's true right now that's true i i
totally um don't think that that's this
this um entity's
desire and i don't think is the
executive director's desire at all i
don't think this is an attack on
midwifery specifically right here and
now but broadly it most certainly is a
danger for us and having
the executive director be in complete
control over these things
they can decide
you know what we want to have our
licensure be three thousand dollars wipe
out every midwife in the state we want
there is a some talk about having
everybody have liability insurance wipe
out every midwife in the state that's
not you know you're not looking at how
this profession is working
and why it's working this way and why
it's
serving the women and the families of
the state the way it is there's a whole
big
um issue
right with medicaid reimbursement all
that stuff and these smaller hospitals
are closing
there's midwives there's myself and a
midwife in littleton and that's the
whole north country you know families
are not and there's very few hospitals
up there so where are families going to
go they have to travel an hour an hour
and have to give their birth to their
babies the midwives can fill in those
spots it's a very important profession
and this bill takes that out of our
hands and puts it into an entity oplc
why
what's what's not working if there's
something not working we need to have
some
level of
protection for oplc getting sued or the
mid-reward getting sued let's work on
that let's figure that problem out
because that's probably across the board
on every board right that's not just
midwifery
that's not the intent oplc is not there
is some sort of a legal barrier that's
right that's what they're telling us
they're telling us we're a small board
we're at risk of getting sued that's why
they're doing this that's
that's the the reason they're telling
this to us so that's what they're
telling us then let's solve that problem
this doesn't solve that problem
what is the problem
if you have if we need to have
administrative stuff going on with our
licensing process we need to have um
rules being made we're working with that
process we are actively working you're
working with it but i don't think you
have the statutory authority to be doing
what you're doing right now that's
that's part of the problem we're not
doing anything on our own we're doing
everything with the lawyers at oplc
within a meeting but what i'm saying is
you know you just mentioned handing off
some of the administrative functions to
oplc
in the past few years
but where in statute has that been
oplc's responsibility to take that from
you we're not asking them to do it
they're telling us that with that that
that's what we have to do and we're
trying to comply with what they're
telling us we're not asking i'm confused
what you said then because you said that
you have worked in the past and trying
to get oplc to to
handle administrative things
but i don't know that statutorily you
oplc had the
was required to do that for you not
until this piece of legislation came
forward
i have been doing it
the council has been doing it
and every time we go to a meeting they
say you're not supposed to be doing that
we have a whole board over here so when
i get it for instance i got a new
licensure to come in right an
application come in
i usually vet it i usually call all the
references i call all the high schools i
make sure that the information is
accurate
and then i
present it to the board the board votes
they look through it they vote on it and
that person gets a license
excuse me
is the midwifery council you're talking
about the same as the board yes sorry
okay fine that's part of my confusion
i'm sorry from the way you were
describing it it sounded as though we
were a separate entity no i'm sorry
that's board and counseling i couldn't
sort of mix them up so the last time we
had a new application come in
i i called the licensing part of oplc a
woman named sharon that we work with and
i said what do you want me to do with
this do you want to do this or do you
want me to do it she goes no do what you
normally do so i started calling and
vetting
i got to the meeting and i said here's
what i did and the administrator of oplc
said absolutely not you're not supposed
to be doing that
i said since when
and they i checked it out and they said
nope and so they took it and they put it
into their
pool of of
um licensing
people right the licensing part of the
oplc
took it out of our hands
brought it back to us said it was all
vetted i said where's the where's the
vetting where's what you did and they
said nope don't have to do it it's not
in your law and that person got licensed
i don't understand how oplc could have
done that because they the authority for
them to handle the administrative part
of that is in this legislation that has
not passed yet i agree with you and i
was like okay and then a new one came in
we didn't even look at it they took it
they vetted it and i said where's the
vetting did you call
and vet this license and they said we
don't have to it's not in your rules
to call like to call the high school
to
call anybody's references and i'm like
why would you even have to have that in
a rule that seems like an applications
that's just like basic administrative
duties right you check out on somebody's
references
they did not
and then in this you're look you're
going to get clarification of what is
appropriate for the office to be doing
and what is appropriate for your board
to be doing right but that's not what
this is this is the executive director
is taking it
completely out of our hands they're
running it
and
you're going to change our it's
it's that would be great if if they were
actually
doing that but they're not so you're
saying i didn't i as a council chair
shouldn't have given them
this application and let them do it i
don't know that that was if the rule if
the statute under the midwife council
i don't think that that was appropriate
then why am i being told by them that's
what i have to do
i don't know why so this is the entity
that we're going to then give all this
power to
this entity that is consistently not
being clear and honest with us
and and the licensing of the midwives in
the state are at stake and that's my
problem with giving all this to
this oplc
at this point in time if they could say
here's
our
licensing operation
and then we look at it we say okay that
works i mean we want it to be consistent
across all boards everybody does right
that makes perfect sense
organizationally every board having
their own method of doing this is a
nightmare
so that's the point of getting them
organized
but we as a board right now you're
taking that
and they're telling us you need to do
this you need to do that and it's not
into the best interest of the mid-rights
currently
and this this
new taking our law and putting
everything into the executive director
and having her oh administratively
you're saying attached you're saying um
that she needs to what was the words um
in consultation with the with the board
on this part in this part that we are
experts on that's absolutely appropriate
if that has to go through we definitely
want those parts in there
but the overall broader spectrum of this
of this
rule this law change
is against the intent of the original 3
26 d
establishing
the midwifery board
the medical board has a medical board
the nursing board right and they're
going to continue to remain autonomous
but the other 54 boards are going to all
follow under
the administrative over
site of oplc that's why it was created
and we're in carving out one or two
specific boards for this
is not oversight and administrative is
great
that's not the same as what this bill is
doing if they're doing their oversight
and they're doing their administrative
job we have no problem well that's again
that's why this this bill is going to be
amended and we plunked out
the the parts that are specific to the
profession that are not administrative
that that's what that's the purpose of
the subcommittee meeting was to pull you
know what i'm saying but you know as far
as like disciplinary action
investigation subpoenaing
the the basic process of renewals all
that all that is appropriate to be done
under oplc
that's an administ that's just a purely
administrative function and that's not
that's not in
that that's across the board that's not
just specific to your profession so
that's what the purpose of this is to
take the things that are specific to the
profession and leave them with the board
to decide how their profession is run
but the rest of this as far as just the
processing of things that is why oplc
was created
well and i would have a lot of faith in
that if i could had seen even in
even last week that that worked for me
but again oplc
it's i just find it peculiar that you
have a relationship with oplc that is
not codified in law
it's
someone's jumping the gun here
so if i can if you want to touch on the
oplc wants to touch on that
well it seems like the right times now
because because it seems like we're
having a bit of a oplc's jumping the gun
here a little bit before this has
actually been
officially established
good morning
there you go good morning
for the record joe shoemaker director of
licensing and board administration for
the office professional licensure
representative pearson just to clarify
so when the oplc was created
approximately six years ago
all administrative functions for all
boards
were put in that original statute
so we have since the office was created
always have had the authority for all
administrative functions for the board
if that makes sense it was a blank just
a blanket statement of authority yes
and that's why we've spent the last
three or four years
cleaning up all this
all of the interconnected statutes that
touch on to that correct it i understand
there is some confusion um again as
representative mcguire just said um
because the
different statutes for the different 54
professions
were not changed or modified
but it's very clear if you go back
through record and you go to the oplc
statute
all administrative functions for all
boards the authority was granted at that
time
that was not a smart way to do that well
yes that's correct with that statute
might have been better done at the time
but listening to the council i'm
concerned that they have
procedures for
processing applications that the oplc
is ignoring and i would hope that you
would take that to heart and
and fix that because things like
checking ref
in something like midwifery where
there is a large practical aspect
you're going to need to check references
and things like that and i hope that
that will be
better coordinated with the board
i want to be careful here i'm certainly
not here to
throw stones and
throw people under the bus
there's a couple corrections that need
to be made
the records for the 38 midwives
up until approximately a year and a half
ago
were at somebody's house it wasn't 10
years ago and it's been a
concern for a long time
as we discussed earlier part of the
reason for this submission was there's
been
many things done that
there's been legal concerns on
the reference to
checking references per se
you can't have
things done that aren't in rule or
statute so for instance if you've
checked a reference and you determine
it's it's not correct and you withhold
somebody's license and there's no law
or rule in place that says
reference checks and i'm using this as
an example
are to be done
that becomes a problem
so we've continued to
have concerns with investigations with
processes and that's why this has come
forward as it's come forward
and when will you be revising your rules
the rules are the responsibility of the
board
we're here to assist the board with rule
making but again and i i don't want to
get into a
you know
throwing stones but again but assuming
this bill passes
you're going to need to enter into rule
making on a number of areas and i'm
wondering when that will happen because
it sounds like there are
that the board is working under a set of
state
assumptions on how things should proceed
that are not actually in the rule but
they
understand are important to them and
therefore they should get into the world
yeah i would say you know one of my
concerns in here is this this law if
passed
would take effect 60 days later as i
think most are aware
60 days to pass rules is is very
difficult i i would say to answer your
question representative mcguire we would
start immediately
on rules
but you know best case if all goes
really well with boards that only meet
once a month jail card that meets once a
month best cases we are
you know probably 90 days 120 days if if
all goes really well
yes but my experience is that once you
actually start into rulemaking people
understand that you're taking it
seriously enough absolutely and that's
why we would start immediately
right and and the other thing too is you
know
these boards
the various boards
the scope the size the effect on
professions is all different and what i
don't want to see
is the smaller boards becoming the
stepchildren of the oplc
right i mean all all these boards need
to function
that again the purpose being to make
government flow better
in any time that we modify government
with that intention and it flows worse
you know we we have to stop and pause
and and look at what what happened right
so
um
we it seems to me that there is a
a clear communication problem right now
and
i don't know if 1061 is going to force
i think it will force better
communication because there's some
things that are going to change
on both sides but
but i do i do understand your your
trepidation with 60 days that number can
be adjusted that's not sure that's not a
problem but
actually it shouldn't
because you
can't actually formally start rulemaking
until the bill passes
right
yeah so we want it to start as soon as
possible
sure
i guess the only other thing i would add
is i
you know i as as
you know board chair
stevens mentioned earlier
i i want to make sure it's it's pretty
clear this bill was created
and if if
passed as written as an advisory board
the authority
you know for ultimate decision making
would lie with the executive director
and that's where we mentioned earlier
and i think
director courtney submitted a uh
amendment uh
that i have here in front of me that
that certainly adds in every place
in consultation with the board
but it seems like there there
was some confusion earlier in our
discussion i just i want to make sure
we're
everybody's on the same page
i don't really see any other any other
areas to
i mean other than what we've done
already for the inside in consultation
part i mean this is a relatively
short one and again the
the rest of this is just all
process stuff
administrative stuff
investigations renewals that's all
that's all paperwork stuff so
um
i can certainly email you a copy of the
what the amendment looks
decision maker like if there's an
advisory board
because that's a single-ended entity
and as
i mentioned before
leadership changes
right so leadership changes the
executive director that we have today
may not be a concern but if it changes
in three years or five years and we have
somebody who comes in who is not in
favor of out of hospital birth which has
happened in other states
uh there is definitely a threat to
midwifery in that case if you have a
single entity making a decision even
with an advisory board so the advisory
board essentially could say no we don't
agree with whatever is being proposed
the executive director is the ultimate
executive director does not have
unfettered authority to make changes to
the rules they have to follow the laws
and we have a legislative oversight to
ensure that that is the case
this chapter that i was just glad about
the midwifery council
starts out by saying
that
we're in what does it say
midwifery
it starts out by saying that the state
is
is part of the culture
that childbirth is a culmination of
pregnancy a natural
process rather than an illness the
services of a certified midwife are
reasonable alternative for pregnant
women and intends that the scope of
midwifery shall be modeled on the
international definition of midwifery
etc
so
we that's that's in the law that's not
changing that's not changing and the
executive director has
no ability to change any of the rules
that would that would conflict with that
okay
okay thank you for that
if i may state also um
for the members of the council that
as part of the activity of this
committee
because as you know we're acting on
these bills for several different boards
and we are attempting
when we put these forward to the full
legislature
to specifically state the intent
of the legislature
is to maintain the autonomy of the
boards
to control their professions
and that oplc does the administrative
and clerical work that we're trying to
state that as the intent going forward
on all of these to protect boards such
as yourself and keep in mind too the
write-ups that occur
that we do when in this is part of
the legal record so when
when judicially when they look at law
they will pull
what we write to look at legislative
intent
and that's
that's why we write them
you know what i mean it's a
clarification thing so and so does the
the lawyers that review the rules they
look at the legislative intent very
closely
yep
okay so
seeing
no other issues i'll close
if you want sure
and then we'll we'll end the
subcommittee meeting
i guess my frustration is
as the
chair of the new hampshire midwifery
council
and i've said to you that i have tried
to work with oplc
and every time
we come up to an ish an issue a new one
comes up you know first it's your small
board then it's you don't have you know
enough members on your board which we
haven't
had a problem with um quorum we had a
small problem this summer our
rules our laws say we have four meetings
a year we have 12 meetings a year so
we've met our
quorum for by four you know so if we had
a few meetings that we didn't have
quorum because somebody was ill we've
met our judicial we've met our law
but it keeps coming up as an issue and
and it makes it sound like it's an issue
it's not
um in terms of the records you know i
have been chair
since i don't know i've been on the
board since 2015.
and when i say i've worked with oplc
when i've done the recertification or
the certifications
or any of the
investigations we've
you know given them
the records i'm not holding anything the
the midwife before that had no place to
put them
there was oplc was
you know and as soon as it came to a
place where we could put them
we brought them and there was boxes and
boxes and we don't know where they're if
i wanted to call up
a record from an older midwife
i don't know where i would get it i'm
assuming it's in there but
on the
oplc site
it lists
who is current midwives and whose laps
it doesn't have the whole history
so yeah that's not unique to you at all
that that holds true for a lot of the
boards and there is someone at oplc that
is working backwards and that's right
and that's wonderful and we know they're
going to fix it i do have faith they're
going to fix it right but you know it's
like now it's been brought up you know
they're holding things in their house
i'm not holding anything and when i've
given something we've had
administrators assigned to us from oplc
that change i give them a bunch of stuff
it changes it goes away
i'm trying to track it i keep it
as the chair so i can keep track of
things so things don't get lost because
this is
an investigation is you know a mother
and a baby a license is somebody's
profession
you know so i'm trying to keep track of
things and i'm constantly getting a new
administrator and saying here's here's
this stuff and i give it to them
and the next meeting they're gone and i
don't know where it is so we give it
again
we're really trying hard i have nothing
against the appeals oplc we want
this burden
to be given to them for the
administrative stuff but the concern is
the control of it
right where is that stuff going and it
if
we could trust that
the um
profession of midwifery didn't have a
stake in this we wouldn't be so
concerned but we are and so i just want
to address that because every time i sit
down to one of these meetings something
new comes up and i'm like
has anybody asked me have you asked me
when they want something what do you do
with it i give it to them happily i give
it to them 10 times if they need it you
know we are not
not trying to work with them
but again
statutorily
we're giving them things that are we
even supposed to be right like
we work with the rules lawyers we've
done our rules several times in a row we
work with the people from oplc sit down
work with them we're giving them
the
expertise and they're giving us the
right words to do it we've gone through
the gel car process several times
you know we're
we're not trying to make our rules
ourselves we're trying to work within
the system the way it's supposed to
right we
the boards make the rules that goes
through gel cart it gets vetted by the
bigger professionals that know this is
okay and this is not
so i don't understand
i i just don't like i understand they're
trying to take all these small boards
and organize them
but i just i'm i'm just a little
confused to where this is all coming
from but anyways
okay
all right i'll uh i'll close the
subcommittee meeting on 1061 here
yes i i saw a note that the governor
intends to
improve licensing and
since he hasn't told me how how he
intends to do it
yeah well that's one of the issues that
was in the state of state advice yeah
well that's great which is great but
yeah it doesn't that doesn't translate
that's a valid concern that the
we need to have better oversight overall
plc and that's
i do not personally know exactly how to
do so well we can model it
well no you can model it after health
and human services health and human
services committee has an oversight
committee for the department of health
and human services it would make sense
that that edna would have an oversight
representative
was going to put something forward for
this
session
i mean it wouldn't be germane to either
these buildings no no well yeah if you
if you wish to do so
i
we haven't yet got any senate bills
but
i've noticed that a large number of them
look like they're dead on arrival
so if you want to come up with a
oversight committee we can do a
non-jermaine amendment because i think
that's not a bad idea and you can model
it like i said brooke health and human
services human services
and it would just put there would be an
oversight committee
that edna would have over oplc for the
purposes of this
of hearing the concerns from the board
yeah
yep
sure we would i mean they're sending us
a whole bunch of days
are they really yeah
like i said dead on arrival and
you